[Music]
the world we experience isn't just given
to us
the brain is actively generating our
experienced worlds every moment of every
day
[Music]
if i'm sitting on the beach
and i open my eyes
i suddenly see before me the sea the
waves i can feel the breeze on my face i
can hear the seagulls in the distance
it seems like there's this objective
world out there and it's just pouring
itself into my mind through the senses
yet i know that's not what's going on
the signals that arrive at our eyes and
our ears the light waves that hits our
retinas the pressure waves that come
into our eardrums
they don't come with labels on them like
i'm from a seagull or i'm from the sea
or i'm blue they're just
ambiguous signals the brain has to make
sense
of all these sensory signals and figure
out
where they came from and what they mean
that's the process of perception
so perception isn't just a reading out
of the world around us it's always a
creative act active interpretation in
which the brain
is utilizing its knowledge about the way
the world is to make its best guess of
what causes the sensory signals and that
that's what we consciously perceive
so the brain has what you might call
prior knowledge about the structure of
the world and about what's out there
that allows it to interpret the sensory
signals that come in and sometimes this
prior knowledge is built deep into the
structure of our brain and it's
knowledge that we're not aware of having
for example that light tends always to
come from above and that means that when
we look at shadows our brain is using
that knowledge so that we interpret what
shadows mean in a particular way
it's not so much i'll believe it when i
see it but if your brain believes it
then you will see it
perhaps the real world just isn't
something that's useful for us to see we
are evolved biological organisms our
brains have limited capacities
we see the world as its most useful to
us in order to survive
color is a very very familiar feature of
our visual experience they give our
lives texture and beauty and meaning
does color exist in the world
well not really no
there are just light waves of different
wavelengths and out of those wavelengths
the brain generates an infinite variety
of different colors
and why does it do this well it allows
the brain to keep track of objects
as lighting conditions change
as the artist suzanne once said color is
the place where the brain
and the universe
meet
this process is going to be a little bit
different for each of us we're all going
to experience our own
interpretations
of even the same sensory data
and this brings up this idea of inner
perceptual diversity
now we're all familiar with the idea of
external diversity we all recognize that
we're different heights different skin
colors different shapes
and we're less familiar with the idea of
inner diversity one reason is that
you can't see my experience if you look
at the blue sky
the blue that you experience might not
be the same as the blue that i
experience even though we'll both call
it blue
there's one example of perceptual
diversity which became
very well known a few years ago was this
photo of a dress that half the world saw
as blue and black
and half the world saw as white and gold
these bits are blue
and these bits are black
definitely
people that saw it as blue and black
were so convinced that what they saw was
the way it is that they couldn't
understand
how other people could see it
differently and the same went for the
people that saw it to be white and gold
don't you see it
part of the reason was that it was a
very badly exposed photograph so it was
very ambiguous and the color that it
seemed to be depended on the assumptions
your brain was making
about the ambient surrounding light
okay if we see that so differently what
about the rest of our experience
how can we assume that in other cases
we're experiencing the same thing
the answer is we probably aren't
can almost be used as a lever to help
people better communicate with each
other because if you can demonstrate
that even something as apparently
straightforward as opening your eyes and
looking at a photograph
can lead to such different beliefs about
what's going on then
we can begin to recognize that other
people may see things differently
believe things differently a lot of
challenges in communicating with each
other might be rooted in the fact that
our literal experience of the same world
is different
it's not that these things don't exist
they exist but the way in which they
exist for me
is completely dependent
on my brain
we do all experience a shared world a
shared reality
but our way of experiencing it
is individual it's unique
and it's very precious because of that
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video